JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hello and
welcome to "YouTube Developers
Live." We have an exciting
show for you today.
We'll be talking about social
media verification.
And I have excellent guests
from Storyful today.
Let me introduce our guests.
Joining us live from New York
City, I understand from a cafe
someplace, is David Clinch.
How are you doing, David?
DAVID CLINCH: I'm doing
great, Jarek.
Thanks.
Yeah, sorry, in between meetings
here in New York, but
thanks for having us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well, we
really appreciate that.
And then, live from Dublin,
we have Gavin Sheridan.
How are you doing, Gavin?
GAVIN SHERIDAN: Hello,
how's it going?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Everything
is going good, now.
And Paul Watson.
PAUL WATSON: How
are you doing?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
I'm doing good.
Well, thank you very much.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz,
and I work for YouTube
developer relations.
So let's get into it.
I understand that Storyful is
the new news agencies in the
age of social media.
So, David, tell us a little bit
more about what your goal
is, and how did you come
up with the idea?
DAVID CLINCH: Well,
yes, I've been a
journalist for many years.
Our founder and CEO, Mark
Little, also a journalist for
many years.
And along with Gavin and Paul
and our team, we created
Storyful three years ago to
essentially be the news agency
of the future.
And the key to our goal at
Storyful is the discovery and
verification of user-generated
content.
And a significant amount of that
content that we supply to
the news companies that we work
with in the US and all
around the world is
YouTube video.
But again, the key to us is not
just discovering it, but
making sure that we have the
original version, and that our
news partners have permission
and access to use the content.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So if I showed a video of my
backyard, which is actually
pretty arid since I'm not that
good about upkeep, and claim
that this is from North Africa,
you guys are going to
be able to actually identify
it as a fake?
DAVID CLINCH: Yes, we are.
And it's a combination of what
we call our human algorithm,
which is a combination of our
proprietary discovery tools
that allow us to tap into
every social media
platform in real time.
And then finally, old fashioned,
traditional
journalism at the last level to
fully verify the content.
So we combine real time
technology with real time
journalism to be able to verify
and debunk videos from
anywhere, any time.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Very
interesting.
Sounds like the human
and the machine
working in perfect concert.
All right, so I understand we
have a quick video overview of
what Storyful does.
So I'm going to ask our
producer, in the studio here,
to roll the tape for us.
And then after that, we'll
talk about some of the
technical challenges involved.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I'm Malachy Browne, I'm news
editor at Storyful.
Hurricane Sandy was one of the
biggest stories of the year,
from its timing a week out from
the US election, to being
the biggest storm to hit
the US since Katrina.
Storyful has built it's brand
on establishing the veracity
of social media content so that
news organizations can
use it straight away.
One of the biggest challenges
for news rooms on a story like
Sandy is the sheer volume of
user-generated content that's
been shared on social
platforms.
You've got to know who to trust,
you've got to know what
to trust, and how to
verify content.
At Storyful, we're very mindful
of official channels
like the National Guard.
We know how to doorstep their
YouTube account so that we get
first dibs on the content that
they're uploading, and we get
to pass that on as trustworthy
content to news organizations.
At Storyful, our mantra is "news
from noise." It's about
finding the authentic voices
on the ground,
closest to the story.
It's about finding reputable
sources, reputable uploaders
of content.
And when we find content, making
sure that that content
is what it says it is.
-A building has collapsed
here in New York.
-One of the consequences of the
Occupy Movement has been
growth in this network of
citizen journalists who are on
the ground in New York, and
other cities in the US.
-Fantastic.
Yeah, I'd be psyched to give
you guys the fridge.
-Power has gone down
in this section.
See, there's some
power still up.
Winds are getting rough as we
get closer to high tide.
-We at Storyful have built
relationships with guys like
Tim Pool, who during Sandy
went out and filmed the
electricity shutting down--
floods on the streets.
He gets it to us and we get it
out to our news clients.
Where Storyful really hits its
stride is finding those gems
of videos, that video gold.
One example is a great video
by a high school student in
New York called Matthew
[? Weinschneider. ?]
A large tree at the back garden
was uprooted, fell
down, crashed through the fence,
and narrowly missed his
neighbor's house.
And for us, we were able to
verify the location of the
video, find his house on
satellite imagery.
We looked at his Google+
profile, his Facebook profile,
and we were able to identify
the shed beside the tree in
his back garden, and the
distance from his back porch
to the fence to absolutely
verify that this was the
location where the tree
had fallen over.
It's a challenge for the likes
of YouTube, Google, Facebook,
and Twitter as well, to make it
easier for us to separate
the news from the noise and find
out what's really true.
-Oh my god.
-It hit my car.
-Oh, the car.
I got that all on film.
-Oh.
-I got that all on film.
-Oh my god.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Fascinating.
David, tell us more
about this clip.
I understand you were
involved in the
editorial process as well.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that?
DAVID CLINCH: Yeah, in fact,
one of the key elements of
what we do at Storyful is that
we have our journalists and
our technologists sitting
in the same
room, at the same time.
Either in Dublin-- in our main
newsroom-- or virtually--
through a 24/7 hangout
that we use--
we are in constant
communication, editorially,
around what new stories
are happening.
But we also have our
technologists, like Gavin and
Paul, sitting with us and
monitoring our tools that help
us with discovering
verification.
And literally, on some
occasions, tweaking in real
time our search and discovery
tools so that we can not just
use the tools that we have, but
improve them in real time
as we approach real stories.
So for instance, today we're
covering the clashes in Egypt.
We have search terms that are
going into our discovery
platform across every social
platform searching for videos.
And at the same time, we have
our editorial team-- our
journalists--
looking at what that system
brings up, and using old
fashioned journalism to help
verify and get access.
So that's where Paul and Gavin
can explain to you a little
bit more the tools that we
use to help discover--
when there are thousands
of videos out there--
which are the real ones and
which are the original ones.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
This is a great segue
into the technology.
I wanted to make a comment that
it sounds like very much
that working for Storyful is
very much an adrenaline sport
because you guys have to do
this in real time, as the
story is developing, isn't it?
DAVID CLINCH: Yeah, it's true.
And we have three years of
experience in doing this.
And also, as I said,
we're constantly
improving our tools.
But it is really exciting.
In fact, I think it's the sharp
end of the future of
journalism.
And we're not just talking
about it, we're
actually doing it.
And in my old days as a
journalist, I always wished I
had a team of technologists
immediately available to help
build and improve tools.
That's what we do at Storyful.
There's no barriers.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great, so
hacks and hackers, right?
DAVID CLINCH: Yeah, that's us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
well, let's talk about the
technology now.
Gavin and Paul, tell us a little
more about how is your
system implemented.
How do you actually do this?
PAUL WATSON: Yeah, so
I mean it's pretty--
there are quite a few different
tools and systems
that we actually build.
It's not one monolithic
application.
We have a couple of Ruby
processors which do a lot of
HTTP calls, a lot of hitting
the YouTube API and a lot
other APIs.
We have a Postgres database
that stores
the majority of it.
In that Postgres database, just
as a note, we have 70,000
YouTube videos that have been
looked at by individual
journalists, and verified, and
annotated, and context added
to them, given titles,
dates, and locations.
We've got 70,000 of
these videos that
are really high quality.
And also cleared and
worked with the
owners of those videos.
And then we have a Ruby on Rails
front end for our own
clients, and for our
journalists.
It's sort of a CMS system.
And then we have a--
it's a backbone JavaScript
application, at the moment--
but we're actually moving over
to Google's AngularJS as our
new front end application
development framework.
And so all together, these
various tools and systems that
we've built really help the
journalists just be faster and
better and let the humans do
what they're good at and the
computers do what
they're good at.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
And since this is a "YouTube
Developers Live" show, what do
you guys use the YouTube
API for?
PAUL WATSON: Well, first of
all, we use it to get the
video details that you don't
always see in the UI.
Because obviously youtube.com
is quite consumer focused.
So things like location and
uploaded data is one of the
most important pieces of
information about a video, but
it's not serviced in
the youtube.com UI.
So Gavin over here, he'll use
a tool, and he'll actually
look at the JSON output of their
YouTube API to get at
the details of the video.
And then we'll pass it.
So that's the main way.
We also have a tool that goes
through all those 70,000
videos and makes sure that
they're still live.
So at the moment we have 6,000
videos out of those 70,000
that are no longer available
on YouTube.
But we still have the metadata,
because we don't
store the actual videos,
obviously.
We leave those on YouTube.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sure, sure.
So this is an important part of
dealing with user-generated
content, right?
Because it ends up in the user's
accounts, it can be
considered ephemeral.
Like users have full control
over it, they can pull it,
they can do whatever.
PAUL WATSON: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So let's talk a little bit more
about is there anything
surprising about your product--
your system--
that you have learned while
building it that you're
willing to share with
our audience?
PAUL WATSON: Yeah, I mean, Gavin
can actually talk quite
a bit about scrapes.
If he wants to--
GAVIN SHERIDAN: Yeah, I mean,
I suppose one of our biggest
problems is that we'll see
a piece of user-generated
content appear on YouTube, and
within 15 minutes there will
be 10 copies of it.
And that is one of the biggest
problems in journalism.
So we need to understand who
owns the original video, and
then we have to kind of track
back and find out, where did
this video originate?
Is this the original video
or is it copied?
Dealing with copies is one of
our biggest everyday tasks.
PAUL WATSON: And then I think
the other thing is spam or
sort of very early uploads.
So we sort by the newest
uploaded date, rather than,
say, the YouTube UI, which
sorts by relevance.
So a lot of consumers of YouTube
don't see the spam
videos that have been uploaded
and which are taken down very
quickly by the YouTube
automated systems.
But if you're using the API and
you're hitting it quite
regularly, you're polling it--
those keywords and accounts--
you're actually going to see
quite a bit of spam video that
you then have to filter
out yourself.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I see.
Great.
Well, thanks for sharing that.
Have you guys tried the YouTube
Data API v3 yet?
PAUL WATSON: Yep, we have, but
it's not in production yet.
We're still exploring
it, especially the
entity side of thing.
A lot of videos don't have
very good titles or
descriptions, so if we can get
more entity abstracted
[INAUDIBLE] out of them,
that's fantastic.
But it's still very
early days for us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, I
think for those of you
watching, we actually have the
Topics API in Data API v3, so
we actually integrated
Freebase.
And then there are additional
annotations available for
content that you can then query
in the Freebase database
and try to reason about.
Because these are semantic
annotations as opposed to just
regular plain text keywords.
Any functionality--
DAVID CLINCH: Just to add
something there, Jarek--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sorry,
go ahead, David.
DAVID CLINCH: Sorry, just to add
something there, which is
very important, when you were
talking about metadata.
In many cases, the videos that
we're discovering have little
or no metadata at all.
They might be uploaded as video
nine with no location,
no other information.
And we're discovering them not
by actually searching on
YouTube, but through a social
search which taps into the
mentions and the references to
those videos from the people
who are at the scene, or
journalists who are
knowledgeable in a particular
area like Egypt or Syria or
somewhere else.
And they're pointing us towards
these videos, with
additional context.
And really, the only information
that we have about
the videos exists on other
social platforms.
So it's very important for us
to understand, and for our
news clients to understand, that
in some cases you will
not find the videos by
searching on YouTube.
But we can help discover them
because they're being
referenced on other platforms.
At some point later they may
have metadata added, but at
the time that they're uploaded,
they often don't.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
Yeah, very interesting.
Sounds like when you think of
metadata, it's in the broader
context of all the social media
signals that you can
reason about.
And that kind of builds
the metadata in your
system about the video.
YouTube is just one of the
sources, and sometimes the
only thing that YouTube will
provide is the actual video,
without any other
signals, right?
But fortunately, you can
actually look at a
lot more than this.
Thank you for sharing that,
that's very interesting.
Is there anything in the API
that you guys would like to
see that is not there yet?
Any things on the wish list?
PAUL WATSON: Yeah,
streaming APIs.
[? Pushnote ?]
APIs.
That's really-- it will
help us a lot.
We do quite a bit of polling,
and the YouTube API is a lot
more generous than, say,
the Vimeo API.
But again, if we can get more
streams of data, it will fit
our use case a lot better.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Well, thank you for
sharing that.
We do have quite a bit of work
ongoing right now to integrate
our synchronous push
notifications
into Data API v3.
In fact, for those of you that
attended Google I/O or watched
the videos-- there was a
presentation by my colleague
Jeff Posnick talking about
exactly how this is going to
work when it's fully
rolled out.
We will post a link to that
video, and then we hope to
have it available soon.
Well, let's switch to the
Moderator to see if we have
received any questions.
I see there's one question that
is relevant, and it's
actually from me.
It's about whether YouTube
Developer Relations is hiring.
And the answer is yes,
we are hiring.
Google Developer Relations
is hiring as well.
You can learn more at
developers.google.com/jobs.
Well, thank you very
much for your time.
I really appreciate you joining
us late from Dublin.
And thank you, David, I
understand he needed to run to
the meeting that he alluded to
earlier during the show.
A real pleasure having
you on the show.
You're doing some very
interesting work.
And for those of you watching,
thank you very
much for your time.
And we'll see you again live
next week on "YouTube
Developers Live." Bye.
PAUL WATSON: Thank you, Jarek.
GAVIN SHERIDAN: Thanks.